government offices and banks were closed
on Tuesday bringing business to a
standstill in many places public
transport workers walked out so getting
to work was an ordeal as buses and
ferries didn't run schools were closed
and hospitals operated with reduced
stuff but trades union leaders say all
thats a minor inconvenience compared to
what workers will suffer next month if
Parliament approves a bill proposed by
the ruling New Democracy party
critics say the three-month old
Conservative government is building on
reforms introduced by the previous
left-wing government that eroded workers
rights this is our answer to the two
pronged attack from the government it
presents itself as growth for all but on
the other hand strikes at collective
wage bargains and Social Security it
limits the way unions work attempts to
control what unions do and limits our
right to strike the previous civics a
government started this but now new
democracy has taken up the baton workers
are further infuriated by government
plans to keep a database of unionized
employees and only allow union votes on
strike action to be done online union
leaders say that amounts to state
surveillance the bill also weakens the
unions power to negotiate wages with
employers by making it more difficult to
go to arbitration if talks break down
the government says that by giving
employers more discretionary power the
new law will create jobs
it's pledging to double the current
growth rate to 4% and also to cut taxes
labor for the brunt of Greece's 8 year
long recession minimum wage was cut by a
fifth and even so unemployment soared to
28 percent unions were effectively
silenced when collective wage bargaining
was done away with even the public
sectors right to strike was temporarily
abolished unions now fear that those
erosions of rights will be made
permanent in the name of growth
obviously doctors pay is roughly half it
hovers just below 1000 euros overtime is
either not paid or paid in adequately
and our salaries simply
not compared to what doctors are paid
abroad which leads many people to leave
the government says flexible labour laws
will attract foreign investors unions
say an obsession with growth is being
used to oppress workers john psaropoulos
al jazeera athens